what did it mean to be married to Chloe
and what does Chloe still mean to you
today Oh a lot you know you still love
her yeah I still got a lot of love for
her yeah yeah
was she the love of your life yeah yeah
yeah would you or could you have stayed
with her
yeah but you know when your attic and
find those demons you can't even really
you're not loving yourself yeah so you
can't even spread the love to someone
that's loving you as much as she loved
me she was loving you but there were
other woman yeah
lots of other women are doing well what
was it
whatever you married one is to you no
I'm saying you got one at home dealing
with another one as weight that's one
too many
mmm yeah but MBA lifestyle is at me on
top of on top of being a woman who all
these other women like to look up to you
know so it was difficult how much you
think you hurt her I mean a lot yeah you
know I I'm blessed
just for even just to pick up my phone
call have you guys kind of made amends
now is it as a it come full circle I
mean I wouldn't call it amends I've
spoke to spoken so recently mm-hmm if
you call that immense huh what do you
think about her and Tristan and his bad
situation she doesn't deserve that she's
a beautiful person from the inside out
yeah you know just a man I guess being
as stupid as I was I mean it's not like
Tristan pulled it together I mean would
you think when those stories broke of
him helping the streets and they have
videos just a bad decision how was your
relationship with the rest of the
Kardashian family especially Chris how
was it oh how is in there I really
haven't been overly fuzzy now we don't
really have much of relationship now do
you think Chris had your best interest
at heart
I think she did yeah yeah even in Vegas
no even in Vegas yeah yeah I think she
did I wish to do or was she protecting
the brand I mean once he's always gonna
protect her brand
you know she's great at that mm-hmm
she's always gonna do that and I'm not
mad at her for doing that but she did
once you once were called down here to
LA you hopped in a car to come see Chloe
you drove down with the best intentions
because you thought you were gonna see
you why yeah that was crazy
and I never really got to speak to about
that Oh even Chloe about that but it was
crazy and and then the headline is Lamar
is acting crazy yeah yeah it was crazy I
would love to have a conversation about
that well cuz there was a point as you
walked away you said listen leave me
alone or I'm gonna tell you the truth I
was just in my feelings all right it
wasn't it was his truth was that they
loves me mm-hmm you know I'm sorry it
was just a bad moment but you guy was a
that's all I'm a chocolate uh there's a
bad moment you would love to address it
though with that wind you yeah you know
I'm saying just to see what happened
yeah if you could say one thing to Chloe
right now what would you say I love you
and thank you for being there for me
when I couldn't walk at all you know
when you would you marry someone
afternoon 30 days I don't think that
lover will go away mm-hmm I'm saying a
piece of paper just says that we're not
together that love will never go away
how'd you know you loved her I don't
know how did you know I mean y'all
listen you met you walking down the
street holding hands well that's how I
knew because I never thought I would get
married so once my heart lost my soul
told me that that was the woman for me I
knew it what is it about her that made
you know I just her love it's like
unconditional mm-hmm like a mother's
love we have this amazing video of um
after Lakers won a championship and
Khloe and Kim are on the court those
were the good days between y'all more
than that yeah did reality show hurt
your marriage or your relationship
no I mean for me I don't know Chloe
might tell you different but anyway just
made everything
it was pure ecstasy with the reality
show just made everything better I mean
we were winning yeah I mean I was
shooting the reality show I won six
minutes a year when I shot the reality
show yeah I don't think that's ever been
done no or ever will be done I don't
think another one of these basketball
players ever even attempted you ready do
you miss it I was gonna say don't sit
there and say you don't miss it you know
that with no reality show I don't know
what I would be I don't know what I
could base it on well did they come to
you the chemical the production company
come to you and say they wanted to do
one with you know if they will if they
want to do what I was doing yesterday
when you look back on your career as a
Laker and you know there's I think
people would divide them in two senses
one pre Kardashian and post Kardashian
what do you remember most what was the
greatest part about being a Laker
well when pre Kardashian pre Kardashian
so before the Kardashian just being
affiliated with the Laker brand I always
wanted to be a Laker Magic Johnson was
my favorite player growing up so for me
it was like a dream come true and then
you know when you get married to a
Kardashian it's like the icing on the
cake no I'm saying being from LA do a
red carpet rolled out everywhere you go
y'all read a quote from your book I'll
read a quote for you look all right all
right I know you so that's why I want to
read you this quote Kevin Frazier from
entertainments and I tried to win family
members over with free fried chicken in
hopes of getting an exclusive explain
and lo
explained that to me I'm willing to
explain that as in your book is in your
book is the bottom is the bottom quote
I can't remember saying that K okay
I'm double-checking cuz I'm Fraser from
Entertainment Tonight trucks and wins
family members overlooked free chicken
come on L oh you know I mean that will
have to be offensive sue right what I
and I'm sorry for that
yeah no I just want it cuz we we go back
yeah we go back in it
we did have chicken while we were here
we went out yeah I went out I took
everybody out you know dude you took
everybody out
I took worse sin downstairs in the
hospital in need have many foods
Oh and so I took about said that that
came on my mouth yeah I said in the book
that what I was sleep let's talk about
this book you put stuff out there
petraju
you held nothing back did you I try to
keep it real I want to talk about Vegas
the hospital and you know when I when
you got there they didn't think you were
gonna make it
and yeah I wasn't gonna did you realize
you were a goner when you were when you
were sitting at that ranch nah it was
just another day of you know I'm saying
being freaky
I guess I'm trying to be freaky you
managed to do that it
I mean I'm honestly I was full for years
I was like this dude is playing some of
the best basketball in the league damn
wood you know when you're at it of
course she's learn how to hide it yeah
I'm saying from the closest yeah from
the enemy some everybody from the public
when did it start when did when did it
really like when is the first time you
remember that you really became and at
and you're like okay well I think that
kind of things like happens like
overnight I don't know if you can really
I would say probably the first time I
tried cocaine yeah cuz I think my father
you know had an addiction problem
mm-hm so maybe the gene was you know
passed to me but you played it a high
high level Lamarr yeah how did it change
your game well I mean it changed my um
my habits mm-hmm my dedication I think
you know those summers you don't change
is running while I think I could have
been just dedicating myself to the game
a lot more yeah over here the point
where you want a championship and really
you were helping to carry that team
Maccoby yeah I mean I had a gift I was
naturally good so if you put me in the
environment while I'm playing everyday
do you think that your teammates ever
had any idea no no because I didn't want
to you know like the one thing we write
in this book like I hope I didn't really
like all offend anybody or anybody
efforts towards me like hobbies efforts
towards me phil's or the Lakers the I'm
saying that had they have anything to do
it I think you did I think it was very
honest and open where you talked about
Kobe coming to see you in the hospital
well and what did that mean to you that
I mean of course it meant a lot yeah I'm
something person of his caliber just
seeing you it you know I should down at
the time from the be there for you you
know right now we're dealing with
operation varsity blues the college
scandal you paid someone to take your
SAT yeah I mean I didn't pay myself but
he probably was paid yeah yeah yeah I
was a stupid decision
I could I could have probably done it
work myself but I think my mother passed
I just said forget school you see what's
goin on down with all these stars paying
for their children's SATs to be taken
and stuff like that yeah what do you
think of that I mean this is crazy
because I'm pretty sure these stars have
the connections to meet these presents
themselves and if they wanted to make a
donation to get their children in the
school they could make it happen that
way and a one lady like paid five
hundred thousand oh yeah that's extreme
you didn't have to pay five hundred
thousand did you mom you said in the
book that you had sex with more than two
thousand women
I never really kept a count that was a
lot there's a lot there's been a lot but
I never counted over that's the first
one and that's the second it's been a
lot
how do you have sex with that many women
I mean there's people who out there who
are like
that's like I mean that's a lot rids a
lot that's a lot I might over exaggerate
a little bit okay you know I mean a
thousands a lot a thousand is a lot yeah
thousands mm is he's like I might over
exaggerated a little bit
I might have been feeling myself him
throws up out there was it always safe
sex no no do you worry about that ever
of course yeah of course when you see
what the results could be I mean you
know seeing what happened our and
everything we all know however all that
is being in LA being on the Lakers
knowing what happened to him did that
ever cross your mind that like a lot of
times but you know in the heat of the
moment make that bad decisions playing
the devil's den here's what I wanna know
and maybe people don't understand what's
it like being in the spotlight in the
NBA where women are coming up to you
what's that like so the average person
who can't understand that what's it like
Froggy's like really hard they explain
when you got your pick of the litter
anyone save the city
every man's dreams like a gift from the
curse I would say was bad decisions is
easy to make bad decisions and you put a
man in that room I saw you in New York
City right out not long after the
passenger Sun jaded we saw each other in
the street gave you a hug and people
didn't understand how much you were
struggling with that did they no but I
don't really expect I never expect
everyone to anyone everyone and anyone
to only one I think I could really even
depend on at that point was which is my
close family members mm-hmm I was lost
family at that point in time but that
was probably the hardest part of my life
obviously on the outside though it
looked like the Lakers y'all are flying
high you're winning championships is God
everything's got to be so good and then
this
nobody nobody understands what happened
with you what did you do when that
happened I just dug deep I'm saying God
on God's coattail and just rode mm-hmm
like I'm doing now yeah yeah [ __ ] have
you come into the light yeah I think
emotionally and spiritually I have I
don't know if it was that um the
accident I had or what was just part of
my personality just my glass has always
been half-full and I feel like I can
just do anything mm-hmm
right now like Superman after 12 strokes
six heart attacks or whatever I had I
don't know gonna sit aside and I want to
know about here today and just tell him
thank you those are my people forever
and the people and I'm San Diego Casa
Del Mar that we had that I went to I
love him favor do you ever wonder how
you're walking around here literally
they were like he's not gonna make it
yeah I mean the the the walking and the
talking part was the scariest part of it
for me cuz I mean I'm a big you know I'm
saying athlete walking and talking I
mean cuz imagine if you just got up and
you couldn't walk on 12 oh I'm sorry was
that that was probably like the scariest
moment that was the scariest moment but
Chloe held me down that's not to say she
helped you through all that yeah dude
she was bringing home pictures up about
my mother and my grandmother making me
say their names oh really
and that helped yeah you wish you could
rewind
yeah yeah but three no regrets we gotta
learn to live a regress yeah cuz they
make us who we are right after that
ordeal after your hearted stop twice and
you had the seizures and everything you
said you stared at gods their gods
they're back to you What did he say to
you what was that moment like well the
feeling I got was you was just saying go
live now
mmm-hmm were you trying to kill yourself
no hell no hey you've never cared Oh at
my daughter's moment my dog is deepest
thought hell no it's no coming back from
that right mm-hmm hell no I couldn't
even help with the lab because it was
almost funny for you matching that I
just see have you read the book I could
probably see well people probably but no
right there be that narrative where
people will be like oh he hit rock
bottom go never I'm good I could kill
myself my kids I didn't know yeah that'd
be the worst way to go I would think how
do your kids feel now because I one
thing that your ex said when she came to
the hospitals the only thing she was
thinking about was like we want him
better the kids want him better yeah
well yeah so I got some really beautiful
and and strong kids and because like
having children like that's the
definition of conversion love because
they have every reason to be like you
just like his pop you know I'm saying
and you know the love that they gave me
I that's the reason why I woke up from
the cold they woke you up they have
visited then they had laughs and I woke
up like this is like three minutes later
or something like that after their visit
me now I mean their love is the reason
why you know I don't even really think
about you know doing drugs now how hard
is it
I mean sobriety is a hard thing every
day innit it's a fight yeah I mean
especially if you think about you know
where we live
seems like the better you do is easy as
it gets
I'm saying surrounds you everywhere what
ask about taraji you really cared about
her did you
yeah she's a hard thing I'll run - are
you surprised no y'all went on a double
date with Brad and Angelina Watts yeah
we got another HBO event but we had some
kind of an awards an event and we were
sitting at the table Brad and Angelina
Jolie Forest Whitaker mm-hmm and that
was one of the nights where I was like
oh like like I'm in here yeah like I'm a
part of the in-crowd
yeah yeah I think that's the night that
we seen Prince before mm-hmm his house
which was incredible night as well yeah
we met at HBO party we hit it off
and you hit it off yeah what happened to
that relationship I hate to say it but
like what happened to a lot of
relationships I was in at the time
Chloe Chloe came along yeah and you were
just like I'm out didn't you know what I
wasn't even a man about it I ain't even
really no you just didn't call her I
don't even know how I do that good
I wasn't a man about it now do you wish
you had have you talked since then have
you all know she probably cursed my name
ball ass you shouldn't be mad at her is
there something you would want to say to
her always got a love for you love that
you're doing your thing keep doing it
I'm making black women proud or
everywhere what's the goal in the next
five years will you do next play a
little basketball you gonna play ball
maybe playing the big three yeah
maybe play overseas or something
Philippines you back in shape you ready
to go I have a shirt yeah yeah yeah 40s
gonna be the best year of my life flow
is it
[Music]